hey guys this is Dennis the founder
thank you I'm David Griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of Game of
Thrones season 4 episode 3 breaker of
chains yeah so after the last week's
momentous episode of king joffrey dine
so we get the aftermath of that and you
know it starts off right off the bat you
know Sansa gettin led away by that
dantas guy that jester guy yeah and we
we find out we don't find out exactly
what happens but we find out another
clue that the Petyr Baelish is involved
with it yeah yep cuz he's the guy who
gets her away he mentions a bunch of
stuff about how he's kind of behind some
of this stuff I think the episode did a
good job of the writers of convincing
people that he was he was gone everybody
everybody a lot of people were assuming
that he was at the Vale he was gone and
then we see like no he's still hanging
around you know in the harbor somewhere
waiting for all this to take place it
was a great scene I mean I loved you
know and they when they killed you know
the Jester and there's a look at it he's
like why did you do that why did you do
that and he's like you know money will
buy you science silence for a time you
know an arrow through the heart or
whatever that'll buy you silence forever
so it's good it's good to have him back
you know he's such a good good yeah cuz
he's such a good like the villain right
yeah you know Joffrey's gone now he was
a great villain even though I hated it
but I loved to hate him and now Baelish
is back and he's kind of a villainous
character that you kind of love to see
yeah yeah and you know he mentions the
necklace he you know breaks it's as
though this was fake right yep so we'll
see how that plays out so now with this
kind of thing we know he's involved yep
with the poisoning I'm thinking that him
in Atlanta Tyrell grandma Tyrell are in
cahoots together some I think Mischa
maybe she did it out of love for
Margaery because she saw how monstrous
Joffrey was good hints of that in their
conversation back in Canada in King's
Landing yeah and also maybe she thinks
like okay the Lannisters still need the
Tyrells no matter what right because she
even mentions the next one so you assume
probably means Tom then you know even
though he's a baby he's a little guy
he's young he's very young but you know
he's a very kind-hearted kid you know
he's not mean or
so you hope he does have hints of that
though I mean he laughs it's you know
the stuff job he was dealing right yeah
last episode so he's kind of very
malleable there he you can influence him
very easily which Tywin loves which
Tywin loves and I think I think the
Tyrells love to and I think you know
they want a position Margaery basically
to be like oh you married Joffrey well
now you can marry yeah Tommy so yeah so
yeah let's let's talk about the the
scene with Tywin with Joffrey's dead
body
yeah and Cersei I mean he's basically
dropping knowledge giving him a lecture
yeah while the dead not even that you
know not that long ago
Joffrey just died right which is you
know funny because search he's like well
this is neither the time nor the place
and then of course she starts having a
little sex but you know I mean it's just
what it is I mean Tywin's business he's
about business he's about the game you
know this is called the Game of Thrones
he's about getting to business he wants
to like get tom and prepared and also
just whisper in his ear you know he's
like well this is what you do like you
know I love the three different stories
you know you know power with you know
and the great strength and the doline is
indeed wisdom and that wisdom comes from
listening to people around you meaning
grandpa listen to grandpa and I will
tell you how to run this Kingdom
basically as what he's saying well
basically he's gonna rule through him
yeah of course yeah and that's kind of
what he wanted to do with Joffrey but
then he didn't realize Joffrey was such
a punk they don't talk about it much but
that's basically what he was doing even
with the Mad King in you know before you
know Daenerys relative because he was
like considered the most powerful man in
Westeros you know even even back then he
would still had a lot of power so I mean
Tywin's always been a force alright and
then now we have this big the kind of
controversial scene with Jaime and
Cersei like it like all over the
internet now they're talking about this
scene because some people are saying
it's sex and some people saying it's
rape it is very rapey this is this
sequence between I mean Cersei first she
wants to kill Tyrion she wants Jaime to
kill him Jaime's doesn't want to they
kiss but she kind of breaks away and
then there's you know and then something
very rapey happens
yeah that's a tough scene to talk about
because especially we're all men here
talking about the situation
we're a man that I'm needed a woman so
of course if I say anything with the
fact was well maybe it wasn't rape and
someone could be like why was raped you
know I mean something to heaven forbid
that happens I'm just saying like I know
that happens I know people that that's
happened to you so I feel awful for that
that's horrible but I don't want to go
into like a discussion we talked about
like you know if it was rape or not but
what I do want to say is there were
times when Cersei when they were
fighting but Sir she was kissing back at
the same time so Cersei she's not stupid
you know I think I don't know I mean
it's it was it was a bad scene it was
rough it was good I liked that the very
uncomfortable very uncomfortable to
watch for everybody with your guy your
girl whatever was very uncomfortable to
watch because unless you hate Joffrey
that still someone's child yeah and the
fact that her father's father was also
his uncle is overpowering and his mom in
a rape not rape scene it's really weird
it's really weird yeah and also I think
it wasn't that she didn't want to have
sex she don't wanna have sex there right
yeah to you know kind of disrespecting
your dead son yeah I mean it's it's
tough I mean it's a tough scene to watch
I mean because it's like we like Jamie
mm-hmm you know and Jamie's kind of I
guess gotten to be a better guy you know
through Breanna a better guy he's not
quite as a douche as much as he used to
be so I'm wondering if because you know
the smarter the writers are very smart
right so they did put a scene like this
in it they must have a reason right I'm
just giving them the benefit of the
doubt I'm not saying you know whether
it's right or wrong I'm just saying I'm
hoping that there's a reason they want
Jamie's character maybe because we were
getting too sympathetic about his
character I don't know yeah they're like
Brig oh wait this is actually who
decided to throw it out to the you know
you know think hear of community out
there like what do you think I mean this
is a very tough scene to watch I mean
did you find this more on the rape side
you find a nod did you find this what do
you think of Jamie was Jamie just being
Jamie was this wrong with him I mean
this was a very it's one of those things
I mean that's thing was game with Owens
it lives in the gray yeah it's always in
the gray it's never gonna be this is
good this is bad so I'm watching them
like wait what's going on here how
should I feel I felt uncomfortable that
that happened but where does it go from
there I mean it's it's a it's a tough
scene yeah that's how Selena yeah well
well speaking of Tyrion then we have the
scene with Tyrion and Podrick yeah when
Podrick comes in visits those touch him
because it's it seems like okay tearing
does have bran but he pays bran yeah
bronze you know a great companion to him
but he knows that the money runs out
yeah right and and they won't even let
bran see him I mean I do think bran does
at least somewhat care about but here he
has a squire Podrick who is totally
loyal to him
not because of money right because he
just feels like that it's it's his duty
and I'm sure he probably sees that
Tyrion is actually a good guy yeah yeah
and he in Tyrion is like no you have to
people are offering you this these
things not because I think he thinks
that Podrick should take it for money
reasons but so that he doesn't get
killed himself right yeah
yeah I mean that was a great scene as
Podrick talking about like you know hey
they gave misdeal and he never says his
answer he says wait my lord my lord
shows I keep telling them what his
answer is but Terry and whatever's
answer is Tyrians like you know lief you
know or don't know sorry take the offer
I'm gonna leave or take the offer and
let me die instead of you die ya either
run away or take the offer but don't try
to be heroic and sacrifice yourself by
like refusing them especially because
Tyrion sees that his circumstances are
dire and even if let's say he does
refuse them and they go to trial
Tyrion is like I'm gonna lose anyways
I'm gonna get hanged or die anyways why
why should you you know let's show it
shows his character I think I mean
Tyrion again Game of Thrones again we're
talking about you know the scene with
you know Cersei and Jaime it lives in
the grey it's not about necessarily good
or bad but it's about tearing at that
moment he's not gonna throw pot under
the bus he could do that he could find a
way to maneuver and maybe do something
to him but he's kind of almost in a way
sacrificing so I was like look I'll take
the fall if I have to die so my ass die
let me die
he's not you know trying to weasel his
way out of it yet I mean who knows we'll
see what happens and he also wants Jaime
he still feels that you know that him
and Jamie are close enough where he
knows if he tells Jaime he had nothing
to do with it right that he'll believe
him and I think deep down Cersei knows
that Tyrion doesn't have anything to do
with it because think about it here
think about how smart Tyrion is why
would he construct this poisoning and
have him standing there with the cup
right that's supposedly poison Joffrey
so I think deep down she must know she
just wants someone to pay I think
that's what it is she's so angry and
distraught that she just sees okay
here's the easiest person to blame
that's why she wants to get Sansa killed
she just sees okay let's kill Tyrion and
Jaime I think he I think he knows that
Tyrians too smart and he wouldn't do
that and he heard you know when Cersei
was tellin Jamie and though in the Sept
there when they were you know saying
around Joffrey to you know make can you
like make sure Tyrion dies were killed
you know basically wanting to wanting
Tyrion dead and Jamie's like that's my
that's our brother you know like we
can't do it like Jamie but they don't
show it as much in the series but Jamie
and turn are actually really close and
they don't they you hint out you get it
more in the books like they are they are
close they do love each other
it's probably maybe wanted Tyrians one
true family members that actually cares
for him and yeah Jamie still still cares
about doesn't I don't think he wants to
you know take him out no no and then
also I think the last scene you can talk
about is the scene where Tywin goes to
visit Prince Oberyn seen the episode
yeah and then you know at first it seems
like he's accusing him because of his
poison knowledge but that's actually not
the case he actually wants the Martel's
to kind of team up with them because
yeah I mean for all of you know you know
how Tywin in the Lannisters oh are you
know the evil ones
Tywin he's a he's evil he's for purpose
he's ruthless right but he's pragmatic
it's not about like he's not like the
mountain know where the mountain you
hear the story of him you know bashing
you know the babies that oberyn's you
know sister her babies and you know
killing her and probably raping her at
the same time like he wouldn't do that
but like he but he does send men like
that to do his bidding but like I said
he's pragmatic it's always for a reason
he's not just evil to be so he is
looking to protect the kingdom but also
obviously the Lannisters I mean he's all
like all about legacy so he wants the
Lannisters to to prevail and part of
that is keeping the kingdom safe and
keeping them safe from dragons so he
knows all the pieces that are moving
around he's like oh these you know this
girl with her dragons over here we still
have a Stannis over here we have Balin
gray Joe we have all these things so he
knows that he needs to ally himself with
the Tyrells and now the Martell is like
so he wants that knowledge I guess they
have
of pushing back the Dragons right and I
love that you know we go get a little
history talking about how you know
Martel's with one group of people that
actually you know could withstand you
know Rhaegar and all you know all the
stuff you know not Rhaegar I'm sorry I'm
the the former Targaryen with all the
dragons and everything so that was that
was interesting I like didn't also get
to see a little bit more Prince Oberyn
he's a little bit over the top you know
he likes his man he likes his women I
love the the young man's question to the
blond kid I don't know his name but it's
his question about like you know you
like both yeah you can do both and he's
like look man I sampled everything like
God made this the guys made this the
guys made that like I liked you're only
getting the half of life if you're only
experience so I mean he's a very
interesting character I like them and
I'm excited he's on the show and now
Tywin wants him to not only be a judge
in the trial binary but also be part of
the High Council right if he gets now he
gets a chance to whatever the talk means
to the mountain he wants to arrange a
meeting with the mountain and then up
north we have Sam and Gilly yeah
Sam wants to protect Gilly by putting
her in a whorehouse but not for those
right not for those reasons
no she doesn't no more work no more
young cooking I never work but it was
sad because Gilly felt like Sam didn't
want her around but really it was he
meant well he meant well because before
that scene of them talking you see they
start showing the who the new recruits
for the the watch war and they're like
thief Reaper Reaper yeah this Reaper
comes oh they were just like basically
pointing out look the people that are
around here right now exactly these holy
men right and then think about this is a
very forgive the term like almost rape
rape the episode and some of the you
know and it's such like a sensitive
subject and kind of a sad subject but
it's just weird it's like yeah you have
stuff in King's Landing with Jamie and
Cersei whatever that is whatever you
want to think of that then you have this
up here you know Sam saying there's a
hundred men you know laying awake at
night thinking about you and she's like
what what about you and he's like well I
care but it's just he has almost like
fear of predators and men and all this
stuff it's really interesting this
episode but yeah I thought I mean Sam
means well I felt bad for Julie he has
to raise the ghillies just to raise the
kid but also when she was at you know
there's obviously you know kind of like
superficial stuff
when she's at at Castle black it doesn't
seem like there's it's like chaos
there's not when they go to the
whorehouse it's like dirty its wow he's
crying she's sleeping at Castle black
she probably has at least a decent place
to sleep right it's like basically
sleeping this corner on this floor yeah
it just doesn't seem sanitary or safe no
it seems like she's worse off with the
hundred guys laying at night thinking
about her I think she's better off at
Castle black so and then also we have
Jon Snow in this for a little bit
because you know Ygritte and her team of
wildlings and attacked this random
village and we're trying to draw them
out and and Jon Snow
you know wisely agrees that no they
shouldn't go out there because otherwise
they're gonna get you know right may not
defeat it but their numbers are gonna
dwindle much more than they need them to
especially if they want to repel Mance
Rayder when it comes right the time
while going to Craster's keep because
those guys they're at Craster's know
exactly how many numbers they have
because he told mance was like a
thousand people and there's actually
only one hundred so if they get to
Craster's keep and interrogate those
guys are gonna find out there's trying
to convince in all of this get a hold
the leaders which are all against him
except for the Targaryen guy you know
it's up for the the maester he's the one
guy that's kind of you know for John but
I don't know kid the more I see Kit
Harington I don't know if I'm as
impressed by him as I thought I was like
I think after watching Pompeii which
that's not a good example Pompeii is not
a very well written movie he does like
one thing well he does like the brooding
moping well I don't know how much I
really see there's all those memes of
him with glass hipster glasses he's like
a emo kind of like oil you know but it
just isn't everybody else don't show us
a lot of bit of range his range is just
kind of like this and I mean Kid
Arrington's fine it's just I don't know
the more I see when I'm not sure if I'm
impressed with him but he's not ruining
anything it's just I'm just not
impressed with him I don't know all
right
and then obviously one of my favorite
scenes is aria now and again I can watch
a whole show on them much like in the I
think the first season with a Tyrion and
bran where I'm like and I could watch a
whole show of them I can watch all show
of REM the Hound yeah no they're very
good I mean it was great I mean Arya is
slowly turning in to being more like the
Hound I mean even the way she was you
know
said thank you for the food the way she
was stripping and eating it like just no
manners just that's the Eagle area it's
funny because she was I mean she's a
lady she was raised in a castle
basically I mean she has those manners
but I mean they're all thrown out the
window now after she's been on the road
for a while I thought that seamless
eating with yeah and he'd the guys
praying right and then hittin the hounds
like basically you're saying you don't
want me to like kill you in your sleep
right right then of the eddy ends up
knocking them out and you know riding
taking his silver which with Aria is not
down with right noticing him again it's
his harsh world of Game of Thrones it's
like there's a lot of thin see there's a
lot of like connections okay so you have
that scene with re in the Hound and hey
this is a harsh world he's too nice of a
person he's not gonna survive this
summer the way or whatever and without
the winter no I thought was interesting
is then you switch and then you go
obviously didn't go they were going to
the wild lanes and you had this dad with
his son i think and saying like your mom
makes the best food some kind of table
potatoes well and then get Genaro shot
you know dead i mean it's like the nice
people just don't if you're nice you're
not going to if you're like Ned Stark
and you're honest you're gonna get your
head chopped off you're honorable
if you're on you're dead yeah you're out
you got a big little finger you got to
be ruthless if your job you can't be too
ruthless if you can't be too much of a
dick like you got smart about it
that's what Tywin said is like the
reason why he's dead is because he had
no wisdom right yeah yeah he was he was
ruthless but just in a cold way where at
least like someone like a Margaery is a
manipulative right she does good things
for people he knows that not because she
herself is very selfless but because she
knows that if you give people what they
want that they're more likely to support
you she's like the you know the pictures
of the president when they're on
campaign like kissing the you know
unfilled you know I'm low income housing
and stuff so I mean it's it's all about
playing the game and then I don't know I
mean the wildlings are the wildlings you
know they're kind of they're kind of
crazy and we get to see you know well we
don't doesn't say anything I don't think
we're good to see a little bit of grief
yeah she's you know shoots the arrow get
to see these new guys these cannibals
you know I was like you know I'm gonna
eat your mommy and daddy and all that
stuff so I mean yeah I guess a little
bit of that and then finally we have a
Dragonstone yep
Stannis and Davos and you know he's de
pissed at Davos let Gendry go because
all these things are coming true now you
know what the leech is like okay here's
you know we put that leech in for Robb
Stark now he's dead we've got elite you
in for for Joffrey now he's dead now
they're just waiting for I think what
bail on Greyjoy is like that is the
other one that there yeah yeah but now I
just have anymore bastards blood no so
so the mill Assad Reagan put leeches on
his penis with it it's not necessary the
guy's got a whole body do not have to
put a leash right there but anyway I
mean so that's interesting I really like
Davos his relationship with Stannis's
daughter I like that I like that as he
was reading you know they realized like
oh wait the iron bank we can borrow
we've heard that the King's Landing is
borrowed a lot of money from the iron
bank as well we haven't met these guys
ever they're pretty interactive bravo
Bravo yeah so everybody borrows money
from they have money more than money
than anybody in the whole world
basically so he's gonna look to borrow
some money that could be kind of a lot
he kind of forged the letter saying this
is from Stannis you know so that's kind
of interesting yeah I like the
conversation between him and Stannis
because you know he's like oh well
you're gonna believe in black magic but
you're not gonna page people right yeah
yeah so we'll see what would Davos gets
up to and if it turns out for the best
because right now Stannis is a very weak
position even though he at least in his
mind has killed Joffrey and Rob right
that that he has no army yeah he has no
army right and what's he gonna do I mean
we talked about he knows what the real
enemy there's an enemy north of the wall
he's aware of it but again cuz he has an
army he hasn't moved he hasn't made a
move so hopefully this to get some
finances little help okay
so this episode we didn't see any fian
we didn't see any brand that was it Oh
Daenerys forgot about that then we have
a sequence why because the title is
breaker of chains and you know she
launches the clay pot I mean that was
that up that was so set up I mean it
just ends it's like you see her do that
she makes the big speech and then dead
end episodes this is definitely that
scene was definitely set up for next
week so of course yeah I really like
this sequence you know with the champion
of Meereen coming out you know
taught them and try and fight it's
throws about it in the nude Daario right
kills the [ __ ] Eric Bana yeah Eric Bana
he's a very different flavor different
man than the other guy it's a little I'm
still not used to it yeah yeah I need to
see some more scenes with him but it was
a good scene and I like the special
effects the Marion look great with the
pyramids really good special effects
it's a good scene yeah because it showed
like more than we've seen before like we
see a huge army we see this big giant
city those expensive shot exactly and
also we get to see Daenerys in her kind
of more queenly Khaleesi state where
she's like you know giving this speech
to the slaves and she gets you know kind
of like Oh like general like right yeah
yeah I thought that was really cool it's
good scene yeah I like all the guys I
love her explanation for why all the men
around her can't fight like you doll the
guy say well I was here before anybody
and then the one guys like well I came
here last and I don't care that it's
like okay you go yeah but you could see
the twinkle in her eye wait after her
yeah she was like yeah because she's got
Lord friendzone with you know what it's
been a while since she's you know I had
a man so you know she needs you got
needs yeah I think Daario is the only
one that she's actually has eyes for
yeah yeah alright but I mean if and when
they do toss those barrels full of you
think it's gonna be like I don't know
napalm or some something like to destroy
the city but really it's a symbolic
gesture yeah oh these are all the slaves
we freed right their you know their
chains we you know free yourselves and
kill all these people you don't know you
know so Susan you at the fight a war
hope exactly alright alright alright
guys so that's what we thought the
episode you can post your constable on
the website fake hero more on our
YouTube channel think hero pro make sure
to subscribe to that we're also on
Twitter I can find Dennis and I both on
there let us know what you thought about
tonight's episode a lot of interesting
topics like a controversial topic some
sad topics list don't think about all
those I think hero I'm at Griffin de and
we also have a Facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans make
sure you like that page and share our
videos on all social media Twitter or
Facebook and all that so no thanks
you